ملف تصفير الشباب التونسيين الى بؤر
التوتر مازال بين يدي العداله التونسيه
قادم في مكتب مكافحه الارهاب اصدر امرا
بالايداع في السجن بحق على العريض بحسب ما
قالوه والعريض قياديه في حركه النهضه شغل
في الماضي منصبي وزير الداخليه ورئيس
الحكومه حزبه الذي حكم تونس في اي علاقه
لقياداته بملف التسفير ويعتبر القضيه
برمتها تلفيقا يراد منه الضغط على معارض
قيس سعيد هذا الاستهداف المنهج لنائب رئيس
حركه النهضه هو محاوله يائس ومفضوحه من
سلطه الانقلاب ورئيسها قيس سعيد للتغطيه
على الفشل الذريع في الانتخابات التشريعيه
المهزله التي قطعتها اكثر من 90% من
الناخبين انتخابات جاءت لتملا البرلمان
الفارغه الخامس والعشرين من تموز يوليو
عام 2001 2020 بعد ان كان نواب الحركه ذات
التوجه الاسلاميه يشغلون نحو خمسي مقاعده
اغلاق البرلماني بمرسوم الرئاسي لم تقبل
النهضه بقرارات قيس سعيد وكانت في طليعه
الاحزاب التي دعت الى مقاطعه الانتخابات
التشريعيه الاخيره
وجاء ملف التسفير ليعمق خلافها مع الرئيس
التونسي ولاسيما ان مذكرات التوقيف شملت
حتى رئيسها راشد الغنوشي الذي استجب منتصف
ايدول سبتمبر الماضي وابقي في حاله سراح
بانتظار اكتمال التحقيق وتقدر مصادر امنيه
ان حوالي سته الاف تونسيه سافروا الى
سوريا والعراق خلال العقد الماضي لانضمام
الى الجماعات المسلحه ومنها تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]